hi reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm John
Humphrey I'm Perry Nimr of Perry
Nemiroff here with our first movie
review together and we're gonna cover
the awesome Netflix movie is it Netflix
all around the world I don't know
actually I think they acquired it so I
couldn't tell you for sure
well they produced it outright for us
Americans the night comes for us Netflix
original before we go into this I wanna
say thank you to everyone who's been
following us on our patreon page over
there we do weekly Q&A s we also do TV
show reactions for many a show that
includes my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood attack on tight
end Gotham Riverdale and supernatural
and John does a lot of music video
coverage and we got plenty of other
reward tiers so thank you to everyone as
a foster their patreon page you guys
Rock and Perry Nemiroff make sure to go
check out her YouTube channel as well
fantastic stuff people now that we've
got all the [ __ ] out of the way
let's talk about the night comes for us
guys general consensus on the film what
do you think Perry you go first
do you guys curse on these videos is
batshit crazy and even though because of
the raid movies I fully expected every
ounce of violence blood at kick-ass
really whatever I'm gonna call it every
single time I got to a new sequence and
they took it to a new extreme I'm like
no way they didn't do they did that they
did that too yeah I was very very
impressed I was really impressed with it
too because I'm a huge fan of the first
two raid films for sure what this felt
like to me cuz this is from the director
and I know I'm gonna say his name emo
I'm gonna say it perfectly correctly
here here's the proper way to pronounce
it tomorrow to hona Tonto so yeah that's
how you guys say it if you guys are ever
doing reviews of this guy's work - mo -
huh - Jon I'm the brown one in this
video
believe me I know alright he did the
movie like headshot oh it was a killers
this felt like
his movie combined with the fight scenes
that you would have gotten in the raid
and I say his movies especially because
it's like the raid choreography but
exceptionally more gory the raid films
are violent but in this movie and nobody
spoilers in here I was like whoa yeah I
don't remember this kind of action in
the rain movies this is insane there's a
whole other level of gore to the
violence across the spectrum of this
movie and that's probably the most
striking thing about it is just how many
splatters and it looked like they got at
least some practical blood in there just
splatter everywhere and this is not to
me at least this is not perhaps my
favorite of their films but it's hard to
deny that almost everything is
impressively orchestrated about it's
like the stories a bit familiar and I'm
used to this kind of movie from them now
I understand what this groups energy is
like however especially when there's
action happening you're just locked on
the screen being bowled over by whatever
horrific it to me I thought it was a
cool blend because sometimes you see
movies with fight scenes where it's too
hyper edited you're like I can't even
tell what's going on I want to just be
able to pass it to the performers and
then sometimes it's like they keep the
shot smooth which is cool because you
can just watch the fight scenes go on
and here it seemed like for every single
move that the performers had to do they
had a shot perfectly designed perfectly
symmetrical in mine it kinda rounded me
of upgrade and the way how the camera
always follows the movements of when if
like someone's particular shot that
caught my eye that felt like an upgrade
shot it's when they're in the the police
van in the back and he like puts someone
over the bench yes it were it looks
incredible I mean really every single
thing you said it every single thing in
this is orchestrated to such a perfect
degree that I kinda can't believe it
especially because these actors are
covered in blood the entire I do come
across as a little bit superhuman but
it's not like anybody ever like washes
their hands clean and like comes out
perfectly qualified anything after it's
like once the first fight happens you
see the battle scars on them the rest of
the way through yeah well the thing is
there feels like there's so
little like XS Hollywood beefing it's
like you're watching these guys really
fight really moving so fast really doing
these hits that look like hits and so
even though yeah there's certain times
we're like I got probably be dead by now
you're like I'm still watching just two
guys in some blood so I'm convincing
beyond the blood though I can't
emphasize this enough
it's a gory film yeah like there's you
see action films are like it's gory
like no it's like horror movie Gore
status with the amount of different ways
people are sliced first fight with joe
taslim when when he's fighting the
people in the in the kitchen the yeah
well first guy who gets his cheek slash
I hate that in general movies
whoa there are times I was afraid to
watch the movie because I was afraid of
what was gonna be so next I might have
been rewatching the third act of this
while I was in the office the other day
and it's like even though I had already
seen it I wish someone was doing a
reaction video you're watching the end
of this cuz every single time I look at
anything like weirdly enough John and I
were saying like should we do a reaction
this can't determine that because we
haven't see the movie and so we were
like yeah you know what let's not just
in case I watched this with my
girlfriend and then I was literally
reacting the whole time because I review
that you paired that liken this to like
Jackie Chan meets John Rambo in the
approach to action yeah the amount of
objects around it get grabbed used in
clever ways and sometimes it's not even
an object sometimes just like a hunk of
nasty wood or something and they always
find ways of yeah like you've seen so
many fights and so much action across
cinema and yet they seem like they hone
in on what's the most painful place on
your arm to get steady yeah or your head
to get stares one in particular that I'm
picturing now that you said your arm the
one we received that girl stabbed so
like it is it's bonkers and kind of
funny but also horrifying and really
like dark at rungy like it's it's so
multifaceted
as an action spectacle alone no story at
all like a science without the story and
a ton of action it's not a hollow
experience the action one thing that
they do really well which is why I think
they can go with such a simple story
like this you like the characters you
like them all especially when they begin
with that group of them together Bob
let's get Bobby a shout out Bobby
kicked ass and he was just like such a
cool loyal guy I really dug his
performance he's my favorite fights of
the moon yeah this is his yeah I guess I
do have an issue with the film though
was that I didn't need this story to be
something groundbreaking or entirely
unique but I'll admit when there was an
action I was intermittently kind of
bored with the movie I wasn't always
engaged that could just be my personal
opinion on the film it's weird joe
taslim the main character and when he's
fighting it's amazing maybe because it
makes sense where his character's going
through a situation isn't why he'd be so
serious the whole time but everyone else
seemed to have more life to their
performances than he did because he had
the very like stoic thing everything
about the plot was so generic when it
comes to the character stuff I feel like
I do get what you're getting at with Joe
Taslim because I feel like the thing
about this movie the raid movies the
what this group kind of tends to do is
populate their movies with fight scenes
centered around eccentric colorful
characters this movie is full and then I
feel like Joe Taslim is the one
character who's not that eccentric or
colorful as compared to almost everyone
else yeah and it's also a very immediate
movie - it is that thing of I feel like
it's a well you don't have to reinvent
the wheel you just have to roll it well
and I feel like this movie rolls its
wheel pretty well but it is like a hyper
familiar triad crime story the way I
read into his behavior though was that
so much of his experience his life was
almost sucked out of him it's like he
was pushed to the breaking point and
that's why he was like a stone cold man
oh no like I get what you guys are
saying I completely agree with the
choices he had for the performance the
story itself outside of the action that
I didn't really find too engaging and
then I found myself going I'm least
interested in Joe Taslim for some reason
for some reason I was just least
interested in him but I'm not like
dogging on the
at all because the main thing you show
up for this movie for is the thrills the
action sequences and fortunately it's
not like it's intermittent it's a lot of
the movie it's like a huge chunk of the
film I mean this movie is a bunch of
Ashton scenes stitched together by a few
bits of story context and yes really all
it needs Teddy and what you were saying
about it not being Hollow Perry is
something that I completely admire about
it because it wasn't I don't know like
you don't when you watch the
Transformers film and you're like I
could care less about the action too
because the everything around the action
is so dull already that I don't even
care about the action in this movie I'm
not saying that it has that level of
effect with a story like I think the
story was serviceable enough that when
the action was there I was completely
gripped and felt the intensity of the
situation I absolutely would recommend
this movie the action just kept getting
better and better it wasn't like you
start off strong and then it kind of
goes whatever from there it just
escalating Lee got more crazy as it kept
going all the way from all right you get
a cool fight Rico I suppose the ball in
the guy's mouth then you get the butcher
fight then you get the crazy fight when
they're all attacking the friends and
Jota sons gone they just don't stop
coming they just keep showing up and
when you get the trio of female
assassins all guys that might have been
my favorite sequence of the that's
probably gotten the biggest audible
reaction out of me to one particular
shot where I'm like no you just did bad
didn't wedgewood shot you get that
moment with her where she knows what's
about to happen and she's just screwed
and it does and it's still uh well yeah
that's what I mean it's like the
ingenuity of things we've seen before
but enhanced we've all seen you know
metal wires in films before in action
movies with the waste they use it as
kind of like a whip in ways well it's
also smart because they they use it
correctly for her character before and
it hurts when you see her use it so then
when it's used on her it has like ten
times the effect yes exactly
julius tell who's in the raid - as a
hammer girl and she plays operator so
that's not me my story parts like that a
little bit of those elements were kind
of confusing to me i wasn't
we sure who she was and at one point the
movie kind of treated it like she was a
figment of his imagination because
there's one point where joe taslim
talking to her and then she's Ansem yeah
she Batman saying I'm like oh wait was
this part of his imaginations acting
crossed my mind when I watch that scene
I think what they meant was that she
just like peace down yeah but but for a
minute I stopped and I thought like is
he just picturing imagine yeah is this
an ex-girlfriend or something yeah yeah
no she's really cool in the film but
that finale fight is one of the best
fights I have ever seen when do you
always count on these guys for is their
finale fights yeah all like 20 minutes
yeah because you a nico ice and joe
chasm are fighting each other by the
time you get to the final kill moments
you're like they're both gonna die
aren't they they're just gonna murder
each other we bloody because I thought
of the raid too when eco wise fights
that one do eagle eyes pretty much
handles business in that fight like he
gets hit a few times gets cut a couple
times he's primarily handling it here
you're like you're putting two icons up
against each other this better look is
equal of a fight as possible by the time
you get to the final moments of who dies
you're just like wow they are they're
gonna bleed out disgust it's disgusting
but like this is this is a super
impressive but and I remember your move
I think already against this and
remembering well I would still be fights
you're you're playing to win you're not
really playing necessarily based on your
own feelings and I was rooting for this
movie to do well but still even after
seeing it this kind of disappoints me a
little bit I don't think it's ever gonna
have that level of success that we were
arguing for on that show even though
this is an incredible feat that should
be seen by anybody who admires either
the slightest degree of action in a
movie like Netflix has this weird array
you watch the movie sometimes you're
like makes sense why this is on Netflix
and there's the other cyber you're like
why is this on Netflix oh not in the
theaters you see Romo you're gonna be
asking yeah
yeah very good if I were to give it a
rating what's your rating system the
Dewey's it's out of five Dewey's and you
can do half Dewey's to do we is the
famous country singer Dewey Cox it was
also not what deputy Dewey Z is a scream
cat yeah he's in your fan fics or do we
Cox becomes a deputy Dewey yeah I mean
if I were to give this a certain rating
of Dewey's I would give it a solid 4 out
of 5 for me I'm not going 5 do is I'm
going I'm going I'm going
4 out of 5 yes as well 4 out of 5 do is
yes I think I'm gonna meet y'all there
cuz I you know part of me wants to go
like that's just a crime film and maybe
give it a three and a half but just the
ingenuity of the action is so incredible
yeah I will go full for for that like
for where you're gonna watch it for
you're gonna get everything you want
yeah this is like an America from what I
understand an American production even
though they shot in Indonesia it's
mostly in Indonesian the money came from
America I am a little surprised that you
have Netflix is where is activist but
you know hopefully maybe now that
they've crossed over into the States
Plus that whatever it was kami who in
the force awakens like I would love to
see them hit the bigger scale American
cinema market because they could pack a
theater and to see stuff like that on a
big screen is all the more intense you
guys mile 22 was awesome and was a major
hit it was satisfying to everyone
go watch mile 22 hey guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation right out
of I mean YouTube questions did you like
the night comes to us what yeah object
would you most like to be stabbed in the
face it's a good question yeah subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell Harry Nemiroff her
YouTube channel it's fantastic seriously
guys go check it out right away
shout out to Joshua Lucero over at our
page Joshua Lucero is a really really
awesome dude all the way from the
hawaii's and I gave him a shout out a
few weeks ago and I sent it over to him
and I'm giving you another shout out
because he didn't reply to me and now
I'm worried of obses tieu get your
still pledged to our patreon page I
would just like it if you can relieve
the anxiety and worry and the tension
that I'm like all freaked out about it
like are you mad at me by just replying
to me and that's all I need
shoutout